I like to exercise but the time it takes
up in my day bothers me the time I spend
running I could be doing anything else
on one of these days a thought occurred
to me putting aside for a moment the
ancillary benefits of exercise like
energy physique mental clarity etc do
the life lengthen benefits you get from
exercising outweigh the time you spend
doing it well let's find out so
according to a study in 2012 published
in the peer-reviewed BMJ that included
over 650,000 participants moderate
exercise like briskly walking cycling
etc for 2.5 hours per week we'll add on
average 3.4 to 4.5 years to your life
but how many hours is that if you live
three point four years longer which is
the low end of what we'd expect that
means that you've gained 30,000 hours
but not all of that is productive time
because you have to sleep accounting for
that you've gained 20,000 but you have
to spend time to get this reward so
let's say you workout for your entire
adult life starting at 20 years old and
you'd like to be 80 so you've been
working out 2.5 hours per week for 60
years that comes out to a total cost of
7800 hours
so what does this mean well it means the
way we think about exercising is wrong
you aren't spending time exercising
you're actually creating time for every
hour you spent exercising you'll get 2.5
hours on the back end of your life so
don't feel bad going to the gym or
stealing a few minutes for a walk not
only will you get that hour back to spin
at the office but you're also going to
get extra time to spend with friends and
family now obviously this isn't the
secret to eternal youth there are
diminishing returns on this so don't run
down the street thinking that you pee at
that but let's say that you're one of
the 80% of American 80 percent of
British 60% of our straining the dolt or
anyone in the developed world who
doesn't get 2.5 hours of exercise a week
it's not that you don't have time to
exercise actually the reverse is true
you can't afford not to
[Music]